ich begrüße markus krampe ein
schwergewicht in der in der
schlagerszene manager ist auch
veranstalter von wirklich großen von von
partys von ja hauptsächlich von parties
eigentlich eher schön dass sie da sind
zuerst die frage sie mussten ja oder sie
müssen ja viele veranstaltungen absagen
bis zum 31 august darf ja keine
großveranstaltung wegen corona
stattfinden wie stellt sich die lage aus
ihrer sicht da haben wir schon
ausweichtermine gefunden oder erstatten
sie das geld wie ist der ihre planung ja
also im moment ist es ja so dass wir
über 20 veranstaltungen in diesem jahr
ins nächste jahr legen mussten und das
war natürlich ein riesengroßer
verwaltungsaufwand weil natürlich nicht
nur die location mitspielen muss dann
auch die künstler wir haben ungefähr 100
künstler auf unsere veranstaltung also
nicht nur schlager und batic künstler
sondern wir machen auch die größten 90er
partys europaweit glaube ich und da ist
natürlich immer auch das problem dass
die künstlern internationale kalender
haben
und ja das haben wir aber geschafft und
seit relativ kurzer zeit steht fest dass
wir alles neue termine gefunden haben
und werden unsere veranstaltung bis auf
kleine ausnahmen also die olé partie auf
schalke und auch die 90er party auf
schalke werden wohl noch stattfinden
wenn die politik dann uns das ganze auch
erlaubt ab anfang september können sie
mir das mal erklären also sie haben
hallen gebucht sie haben künstler
gebucht jetzt findet nicht statt müssen
sie die hallen trotzdem bezahlen müssen
die künstler trotzdem honorieren wie ist
da so die rechtliche lage überhaupt also
es ist von bis das kommt natürlich immer
auf den persönlichen kontakt glaube ich
an denen man zu den künstlern auch zu
den managern hat und auch zu der
location betreibern
grundsätzlich glaube ich haben alle
gemerkt dass wir in einem boot sitzen
und das wenn da irgendwie einer quer
schießt das natürlich auch viele große
veranstalter in probleme kommt wir haben
zum beispiel in diesem jahr ungefähr 30
veranstaltungen über 500.000 besuchern
die wir gehabt hätten
und das ist
natürlich in der branche ganz relativ
groß und natürlich versuchen wir uns mit
allen dingen die so zu stellen dass es
auch funktioniert und so erwarten wir es
natürlich auch von unseren partnern das
hat im großen und ganzen auch geklappt
es gab zwei drei problemfälle dann ein
bisschen nachjustieren mussten aber auch
das haben wir geregelt und wie ist das
jetzt also sie sagten die
veranstaltungen finden dann im nächsten
jahr startklar da wird es ja
wahrscheinlich dann auch wieder partys
geben zurzeit ja das ist ein absolutes
tabu ich weiß auch gar nicht wann in
diesem jahr wieder richtig gefeiert
werden kann clubs und diskotheken sind
ja auch noch geschlossen
wie ist das wenn jetzt zum beispiel ein
zuschauer sagt ich weiß gar nicht im
nächsten jahr bin ich dafür zu alt oder
da möchte ich nicht daran teilnehmen wie
gehen sie dann vor
also es war ja am anfang eine relative
rechtsunsicherheit oder eine
unsicherheit wie die bundesregierung
jetzt auch uns vorgaben macht und
ursprünglich wurde dann ja und das ist
glaube ich das heißt der anwalt der
seine besser ist es eine goodwill aktion
der kunden dass sie gesagt haben
da kommen wir verzichten auf die
rückerstattung in dem eventuell
gutscheine oder nimmt die
gutscheinlösung in anspruch aber mir ist
sehr wohl bewusst dass wir als
veranstalter natürlich dafür gerade
stehen müssen die ticket gelder auch
zurückzuerstatten das ist nicht immer
ganz einfach weil wir natürlich mit
wären ticket anbietern arbeiten auch
vielen großen namhaften und ja die haben
sich am anfang noch ein bisschen quer
gestellt haben gesagt nach dem motto
lasst uns erst mal abwarten wie die
rechtliche situation ist jetzt sollte ja
vor kurzem eine entscheidung in der
bundesregierung gefällt werden das als
ich glaube ich um ein paar tage
verzögert oder soll jetzt am 15
gemacht denn wir sind am anfang her
gegangen und haben ticket geld
rückerstattet direkt und alle die sich
jetzt bei uns melden weil natürlich wenn
die kunden beim ticket anbieter nicht
weiterkommen
ähnlich wie ihr anwalt das vor kurzem
empfohlen hat melden die sich bei uns
als veranstalter und wir arbeiten das
gerade so ist es lieber ab und der stadt
natürlich die ticket gelder zurück
wollen wir doch gleich an kempkens der
wurde von ihm gerade zum wunderschönen
an moderiert gleich mit dazu nehmen also
tatsächlich haben wir hier auch schon
viele zuschauer auch beraten
tatsächlich geht es dann darum muss sich
einen gutschein akzeptieren an kempkens
hat festgestellt dass die lesung dieses
so genannten gutschein gesetzes noch mal
vertagt worden ist
das heißt zur zeit gibt es diese
gutscheinlösung noch nicht man kämpfe
etwas ist der neueste stand genau das
ist der fall ist es natürlich jedem
selber überlassen ob er das akzeptiert
also ist es ja auch nichts dagegen
einzuwenden wenn der kunde von sich aus
sagt ich möchte eben den veranstalter
unterstützen ich will das geld im moment
noch nichts sagen sondern ich schaue mir
den markt an
ich lasse mich auch das ersatzkonzert
ein oder so das ist vollkommen okay und
ich bin auch gar nicht unbedingt dazu
aufrufen das eben nicht zu machen
sondern es geht ja darum was will der
kunde eigentlich was will der
verbraucher was wird der ticket inhaber
von daher ist es absolut legitim dass
eben auch zu stunden und eben noch nicht
zurück zu verlangen nur die leute die
eben zurückverlangen die haben eben den
anspruch drauf und da meine ich das ist
genau richtig ist wieder veranstaltet
jetzt zu recht sagt dann reagieren wir
auch und dann arbeiten wir das ab und
genau das ist richtig so und das ist
auch gut so und was die ticket lösung
selber also die gutscheinlösung für die
deutschen tickets anbelangt da brauchen
wir ja keine eu abstimmung wie bei den
reisen sondern das kann auch
bundesdeutscher ebene gemacht werden und
da müssen wir sehen wie das weitergeht
da gibt es ja so ein paar anträge auch
von verschiedenen anderen partei das ist
ja die regierungsparteien die das eben
ins in den bundestag eingebracht haben
das sollte eigentlich letzte woche ja
abschließend beschlossen werden oder
beredet werden aber da war eben noch
beratungsbedarf an es gibt ja auch viel
kritik daran
und da müssen wir mal sehen wie das
weitergeht wir haben tatsächlich auch
schon die unsere zuschauer beraten wie
ich jetzt vorgehe wenn ich jetzt ein
ticket habe also zum beispiel wo wir es
doch noch mal durchgehen also ich gucke
auf das ticket drauf und stelle dort
fest herr krampe ist mit seiner firma
der veranstalter das heißt ich möchte
müsste mich auch an herrn krampe nicht
an ihn persönlich werden aber an seine
firma wenn ich das geld zurückhaben will
wie ist das werk rampe sie sagte haben
das von angedeutet da haben sich so die
vermittler also die ticket aussteller so
ein bisschen angestellt oder wer ist
letztlich dann aus ihrer sicht
zuständige auf meiner sicht sind sie ja
da gebe ich ihnen recht da kann man noch
nicht wieder sprechen wir sind die
veranstalter und im endeffekt auch der
geldempfänger allerdings ist der der
erste
vielleicht alles erklären er werde das
geld einnimmt ist der ticketanbieter und
schüttet an uns aus das sind auch noch
nicht alle gelder ausgeschüttet worden
an uns so dass es da handlungsbedarf
gabe und redebedarf dass wir erst mal
mit den ticki park angesprochen haben
gesagt passt mal auf die kunden wenden
sich jetzt an uns die wollen ihr geld
zurück haben wir müssen uns ausschütten
also müssen das auch von euch erstmal
bekommen und das ist jetzt passiert bei
den meisten und wird wie gesagt so
christina abgearbeitet allerdings muss
ich auch dazu sagen es sind gar nicht so
viele leute die ihr geld zurückhaben
möchte sind immer härtefälle die sagen
ich habe zu dem termin irgendwie eine
hochzeit oder tatsächlich den runden
geburtstag oder es war ein
junggesellenabschied wo wir deswegen für
die karten gekauft haben den gibt es
jetzt ja leider nicht deswegen wollen
wir die karten vielleicht umtauschen
es war aber auch ganz häufig der fall
dass viele leute geschrieben haben dass
man auch wir verstehen uns als
veranstalter wir haben vollstes
verständnis dass es jetzt ins nächste
jahr gelegt werden muss und deswegen
behalten wie die karten beziehungsweise
neben die gutscheinlösung vielleicht für
eine andere veranstaltung also ist er
wenn man das in prozent beziffern würde
ist bei uns der rücklauf noch nicht mal
25 prozent aller aller ticketkäufer und
das ist auch sehr gut so glaube ich hier
schon oft das thema das die leute halt
zwischen dem vermittler und dem
veranstalter hin und her geschoben
werden
sie haben gerade gesagt das geld ist
auch noch gar nicht bei ihnen angekommen
ist natürlich dann auch schwer das geld
zu überweisen
hängt das dann so lange beim beim ticket
aussteller weil die halt sagen naja wie
ist wie können nichts dafür da ist muss
der veranstalter gerade stehen aber wenn
sie das geld noch nicht haben ja wo ist
das geld dann also es ist so dass wenn
sie ticket kaufen das dass das natürlich
erst mal mein ticket anbieter landet der
das geld für uns vereinnahmt und nach
einem gewissen zyklus entweder monatlich
je nachdem wie wir es vereinbart haben
wie die ausschüttungen bekommen und da
gab es tatsächlich schwierigkeiten dass
einige ticket anbieter auf sich uns
gegenüber gesträubt haben haben haben
gesagt moment wir behalten das geld
jetzt erstmal wissen ja noch gar nicht
wie die rechtliche situation aussieht
ich habe dann entschieden dass wir das
geld bekommen möchten und dass wir die
kunden zufrieden stellen möchten wir
sind dann auch teilweise in vorleistung
getreten wenn leute hier geschrieben
haben uns sich an uns gewendet haben
dann gesagt wir möchten oder geld zurück
dann haben wir das gemacht weil wir wie
gesagt wir sind jetzt seit 15 jahren am
markt und im endeffekt bleibt an uns
hängen
man kennt den namen der verantwortung
sagt die haben uns hier veräppelt haben
das geld nicht zurückgezahlt das wollte
ich vermeiden und deshalb haben wir
allen gästen jetzt die zusage gemacht
dass wir das geld zurückerstatten und
das ist wie gesagt gerade dran das auch
so zu tun
jetzt haben wir wahrscheinlich noch ein
paar tage zeit bis diese gutscheinlösung
in kraft tritt muss ich mich an kempkens
jetzt sofort am besten an markus krampe
wenden bevor dieses gesetz dann wirklich
verabschiedet ist oder er ist das habe
ich ja noch ein bisschen zeit also die
gesetzliche regelung sollte er
tatsächlich diese tickets umfassen
und wenn das tatsächlich in kraft tritt
dann würde es im bundesgesetzblatt
verkündet werden und einen tag später in
kraft treten und ab dann wäre eben diese
gutschein möglichkeit gegeben
und wer eben das nicht akzeptieren will
der sollte tatsächlich sich an den
veranstalter direkt wenden und wenn wir
einen kampl gerade und sagt ja zu recht
wir zahlen sofort aus als es ist
wunderbar
wir erleben in der praxis ganz andere
veranstalter die das eben also auch die
die kunden auch sehr verein und hier
irgendwie die leute hinhalten und da
irgendwie völlig falschen rechtlichen
hinweisen auch in denen wir teilweise
geschrieben wird wir müssen ihnen einen
gutschein ausstellen wir dürfen gar
nicht bezahlen und so was alles lesen
praxis in so e mails und das ist einfach
nicht in ordnung und deswegen ist das
umso besser dass sie hier ein
veranstalter auch hier ganz deutlich
sagt ich bin der kommunikation wichtig
ich finde es wichtig auch den kunden
gegenüber und man sieht auch den erfolg
wir sehen doch hier einen ein fairer
veranstaltet er hier sauber das
abwickelt er hat hier eine
rückzahlungsquote von fünf prozent das
ist doch wirklich absolut erträglich und
das liegt auch daran dass wir gut
kommuniziert wird und wenn die
veranstalter global das so machen haben
wir auch gar kein problem wenn die
veranstalter aber mauern
dann werden die dann werden natürlich
die kunden auch sauer und dann kommen
sie nämlich zu den anwälten und sagen
jetzt müsst ihr klaren ja und dann gibt
es ja auch gar keine andere möglichkeit
denn es ist ja nicht etwa so dass die
anwaltschaft insgesamt
wild auf solche klagen ist das ist gar
nicht der fall sondern will einfach eine
faire lösung für die kunden
letzte frage noch an markus krampe wie
ist es sie stellen sich jetzt hier hin
sie sind natürlich auch bekannt sie sind
natürlich auch keinen lohn
ich habe mir mal so angeguckt wer
überhaupt bei so vielleicht nicht bei
den ganz großen konzerten aber sogar die
mittelgroßen konzerten so veranstalter
sind das wird zum teil so ein bisschen
wie home office also das sind halt keine
großen firmen die auch noch nie in der
öffentlichkeit stehen die haben zum teil
auch gar kein impressum auf ihren seiten
wie ist denn da was sagen sie auch
ticket besitzern wie geht das weiter
oder gibt es dann welche die einfach
abtauchen und dann konkurs anmelden wie
sehen sie die zukunft
ja das hat man ja sogar schon vor corona
gesehen dass es immer wieder schwarze
schafe gibt die einfach denken ach komm
ich mache mir jetzt so eine
schlagerparty oder eine party kündigen
paar künstler an und bieten der location
und mal was passiert verkauften karten
und ist ganz häufig so passiert das dann
kurze zeit später auf einmal kam ja
moment nähe das rechnet sich alles doch
nicht und wir sagen dass ab und auf
einmal waren die veranstalter nicht mehr
auffindbar
deswegen kann ich nur jedem raten wenn
er sich ein ticket kauft sich auch ein
bisschen damit auseinander zu setzen
wäre vielleicht dahinter steckt sind das
leute die jahrelang markt sind oder die
auch schon erfahrungen haben in diesem
bereich weil veranstaltung zu machen ist
nicht so ganz einfach man steht morgens
auf und sagt auf einmal ja komm ich kann
das das ist glaube ich eine antrag wie
viele andere auch die man lernen muss
und wo man auch jahrelange erfahrungen
mit haben muss und dann kann man das
auch vernünftig machen ja warnt markus
krampe partyveranstalter und auch
manager und der kennt sich aus noch eine
letzte frage thema ballermann
sie veranstalten natürlich auch mallorca
partys wie geht's am ballermann weiter
wird da in diesem jahr noch irgendwann
gefeiert was es da ihre einschätzung
also wir haben ja einen durch unsere
künstler die wir auch im megapark und
ihr könig zum beispiel vor ort haben wir
betreuen ja michael wendler oder auch
mehr julia und viele andere bin ich
natürlich im engen austausch mit den
betreibern der locations und vor zwei
drei wochen
würde ich sagen weil ich bin noch sehr
bedrückt und da haben wir alle gesagt
wir glauben nicht dass dieses jahr noch
irgendetwas passiert seitdem lockerungen
nicht nur hier in deutschland sondern
auch auf mallorca sind alle ja ich würde
mal sagen leicht euphorisch das
vielleicht im mitte august vielleicht im
september noch ein bisschen gefeiert
werden kann
ja wir wissen dass alle nicht wie es
ausgeht wir hoffen natürlich nur ich
würde mich für jeden freund der gerne so
eine art von partys machen auf die
künste natürlich das noch klappt und wir
kommen dann auch feiern an camp benutze
ich vielen dank vielen dank für dieses
gespräch herr krampe vielleicht bis zum
nächsten mal in dieser sendung